The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Hey, everybody.
Let's get started here.
So last time we had the
skull and crossbones,
this time we're going to have
double skull and crossbones.
This stuff is really
hard and really fun.
And we're going to talk about
synchronization without locks.
And to start out, I want to
talk about memory models.
And in particular, the
most important memory model
from a theoretical point of
view, which is sequential
consistency.
And to introduce it, I
want to use an example
to introduce the notion
of a memory model.
So suppose you have
two variables, a
and b, which are initially
0, and those variables
are stored in memory.
And processor 0 moves
a 1 into a, then
it moves the contents
of ebx into b.
And meanwhile processor
1 moves a 1 into b,
and moves the contents
of a into eax.
I just chose different
registers just so we
can distinguish the two things.
Now let's think about this code.
We have these two
things going on.
Is it possible that processor
0's ebx and processor
1's eax both contain the value
0 after the processors have both
executed their code?
They're executing in parallel.
So think about a little bit.
This is a good lecture to think
about because, well, you'll
see in a minute.
So can they both
have the value of 0?
So you're shaking your head.
Explain why?
STUDENT: So if ebx is
greater than [INAUDIBLE]
then it's [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, good.
And that's a correct
argument, but you're
making a huge assumption.
Yeah, so the idea is that, well,
if you're moving a 1 into it,
you're not looking at it.
It may be that one of them
gets 0, and the other gets 1,
but it actually turns
out to depend on what's
called the memory model.
And it took a long time before
people realized that there
was actually an issue here.
So this depends upon
the memory model.
And what you were
reasoning about
was what's called
sequential consistency.
You were doing happens
before types of relationships
and saying, if this
happened before that, then.
And so you had some
global notion of time
that you were using to say what
order these things happened in.
So let's take a look at the
model that you were assuming.
It's interesting, because
whenever I do this,
somebody always has
the right answer,
and they always assume that
it's sequentially consistent.
It's the most standard one.
So sequential
consistency was defined
by Leslie Lamport who won the
Turing Award, a few years ago.
And this is part of
the reason he won it.
So what he said is, the
result of any execution
is the same as if the
operations of all the processors
were executed in some
sequential order.
And the operations of
each individual processor
appear in this sequence in the
order specified by the program.
So let's just break
that apart, because it's
a mouthful to understand.
So the sequence of instructions
as defined by a processor's
program are interleaved with the
corresponding sequences defined
by the other
processors' programs
to produce a global linear
order of all instructions.
So you take this
processor, this processor,
and there's some way of
interleaving them for us
to understand what happened.
That's the first part
of what he's saying.
Then after you've done
this interleaving,
a load instruction is going
to get the value stored
to the address of the load.
That is, the value
of the most recent
stored to that same location
in that linear order.
So by most recent, I mean most
recent in that linear order.
I'm going to give an
example in just a second.
So it doesn't fetch
one from way back,
it fetches the most
recent one, the last write
that occurred to that location
in that interleaved order
that you have picked.
Now there could be many
different interleaved orders,
you can get many
different behaviors.
After all, here we're talking
about programs with races,
right?
We're reading stuff that
other things are writing.
And so basically, the hardware
can do whatever it wants.
But for the execution to be
sequentially as consistent,
it must appear as if the
loads and stores obeyed
some global linear order.
So there could be many different
possible execution paths,
depending upon how
things get interleaved.
But if you say, here's the
result of the computation,
it better be that
there exists one
of those in which
every read occurred
to the most recent write
according to some linear order.
Does that makes sense?
So let's do it for this example.
So here we have our setup again.
How many interleavings
of four things are there?
Turns out there's
six interleavings.
So those who've taken 6.042
will know that, right?
4 choose 2.
So the interleavings,
you can do them
in the order 1, 2, 3, 4,
1, 3, 2, 4, 1, 3, 4, 2,
et cetera, et cetera.
But notice that in every
one of these orders,
1 always comes before 2,
and 3 always comes before 4.
So you have to respect
the processor order.
The processor order,
you have to respect it.
So if I execute in the first
column, if that's the order,
what's the value that I end
up with for eax and ebx?
STUDENT: 1 and 0.
CHARLES LEISERSON: 1 and 0.
Yep.
So it basically moves a 1 into
a, then it moves b into ebx.
b is currently 0, so
it's got a 0 in ebx.
Then processor 1 moves 1 into b.
And then it moves a into eax.
And a at that point
has the value 1.
What about the second one?
STUDENT: 1, 1.
CHARLES LEISERSON: 1, 1.
Good.
Because they basically are both
moving 1 into their registers,
then they're both storing.
What about the third one?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Same.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Same.
OK, fourth one?
We'll try to get
everybody [INAUDIBLE]..
STUDENT: Same.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Same?
Yep.
Fifth one?
Same.
Last one?
STUDENT: 0, 1.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, 0, 1.
Good.
So this is the
total number of ways
we could interleave things.
We don't know which
one of these might
occur because, after
all, the output is
going to be non-deterministic
upon, which it is.
But one thing that we
can say for certain
is that if you have
sequential consistency,
there's no execution
that ends with them both
being 0, which is exactly
your intuition and correct
rationalization.
But it turns out interestingly
that of modern computers, none
implement sequential
consistency.
Why?
Because life would
be too easy then.
None of them do that.
So we'll get there, we'll talk
about what modern machines do.
So let's reason about
sequential consistency.
So the way that you can
formally reason about this,
to make an argument as
you might have for example
on a quiz, if we had
a quiz coming up,
would be to understand
that an execution induces
a happens before a
relationship that we
will denote as a right arrow.
And the right arrow
relation is linear,
meaning that for
any two instructions
either one happens before
the other or the other
happens before the one for any
two different instructions.
This is the notion
of a linear order.
The arrow relation
has to respect.
The happens before relation
has to respect processor order.
In other words, that within
the instructions executed
by a processor the
global order has
to have those same
sequence of instructions
of whatever that processor
thought that it was doing.
And then a load from
a location in memory
reads the value
written by the most
recent store to that location
according to happens before.
And for the memory
resulting from an execution
to be sequentially
consistent, there
must be a linear order that
yields that memory state.
If you're going to write
code without locks,
it's really important to be
able to reason about what
happened before what.
And with sequential
consistency, you just
have to understand what are
all the possible interleavings.
So if you have n instructions
here and m instructions there,
you only have to worry about n
times m possible interleavings.
Actually, is it n times m?
No, you've got more than that.
Sorry.
I used to have good math.
So one of the celebrated results
early in concurrency theory
was that fact that you could do
mutual exclusion without locks,
or test and set, or
compare and swap,
or any of these
special instructions.
Really remarkable
result. And so I'd
like to show you that
because it involves thinking
about sequential consistency.
So let's recall, we talked
about mutual exclusion last time
and how locks could
solve that problem.
But of course locks
introduced a lot
of other things like
deadlock, convoying,
and a variety of
things, some of which
I didn't even get a
chance to talk about,
but they're in
the lecture notes.
So let's recall that a critical
section is a piece of code that
accesses a shared data
structure that you
don't want two separate
threads to be executing
at the same time.
You want it to be
mutually exclusive.
Most implementations use one
of these special instructions,
such as the xchg, the exchange
instructions we talked about
to implement locks last time.
Or they may use test and
set, compare and swap,
load linked store conditional.
Are any of these
familiar to people?
Or is this new stuff?
Who's this new for?
Just want to make sure.
OK, great.
So there are these
special instructions
in the machine that do things
like an atomic exchange,
or a test and set.
I can set a bit and test
what the prior value was
of that bit as an
atomic operation.
It's not two sections
where I set it,
and then the value
changed in between.
Or compare and swap, we'll talk
more about compare and swap.
And load linked store
conditional, which is even
a more sophisticated one.
So in the early days of
computing back in the 1960s,
this problem of mutual
exclusion came up.
And the question was,
can mutual exclusion
be implemented with only
the loads and stores
as the only memory operations.
Or do you need one
of these heavy duty
instructions that does two
things and calls it atomic?
Oops, yep, so I
forgot to animate
the appearance of Edsgar.
So two fellows, Dekker and
Dijkstra, showed that it can,
as long as the computer system
is sequentially consistent.
And so I'm not going to
give their algorithm, which
is a little bit complicated.
I'm going to give I what
I think is boiled down
to the most simple and
elegant version of that
uses their idea, and
it's due to Peterson.
And for the life
of me, I have not
been able to find a
picture of Peterson.
Otherwise, I'd show you
what Peterson looks like.
So here's Peterson's algorithm.
And I'm going to model
it with Alice and Bob.
They have a shared widget.
And what Alice wants to do
to the widget is to frob it.
And Bob wants to borf it.
So they're going to
frob and borf it.
But we don't want them to
be frobbing and borfing
at the same time, naturally.
You don't frob and borf
widgets at the same time.
So they're mutually exclusive.
So here's Peterson's algorithm.
So we have widget x.
So I'm just going to read
through the code here.
And I have a Boolean
variable called wants.
I have an A_wants and a B_wants.
A means Alice wants
to frob the widget.
B_wants means that Bob
wants to borf the widget.
And we're also going to have a
variable that has two values, A
or B, for whose turn it is.
And so we start
out with that code,
and then we fork the two
Alice and Bob branches
of our program to
execute concurrently.
And what Alice does is
she says, I want it.
She sets A_wants to true.
And I set the turn
to be Bob's turn.
And then the next loop
has an empty body, notice.
It's just a while
with a semicolon.
That's an empty body.
It's just going to
sit there spinning.
It's going to say, while
B wants it, Bob wants it,
and it's Bob's turn,
I'm going to just wait.
And if it turns out that
either Bob does not want it
or it's not Bob's
turn, then that's
going to free Alice to go into
the critical section and frob
x.
And then when she's done she
says, I don't want it anymore.
And if you look at Bob's code,
it's exactly the same thing.
And when we're done
with this code,
we're going to then loop to
do it again, because they just
want to keep
frobbing and borfing
until their eyes turn blue or
red, whatever color eyes they
have there.
Yeah, question?
I didn't explain
why this works yet.
I'm going to explain
why it works.
STUDENT: OK.
CHARLES LEISERSON: You're
going to ask why it works?
STUDENT: I was going to
ask why those aren't locks.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Why
are they not locks?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Well, a lock says
that if you can acquire it,
then you stop the other person
from acquiring it.
There's no locking here,
there's no waiting.
We're implementing a
mutual exclusion region.
But a lock has a
particular span--
it's got an acquire
and a release.
So when you say A
wants to be true,
I haven't acquired the
lock at that point, have I?
Or if I set the turn to
be the other character,
I haven't acquired a lock.
Indeed, I then do some testing
and so forth and hopefully
end up with mutual exclusion,
which is effectively
what locking does.
But this is a different
way of getting you there.
It's only using
loads and stores.
With a lock, there's an atomic--
I got the lock.
And if it wasn't available,
I didn't get the lock.
Then I wait.
So let's discuss, let's
figure out what's going on.
And I'm going to do it two ways.
First, I'm going to
do the intuition,
and then I'm going to show
you how you reason through it
with a happens before relation.
Question?
STUDENT: No.
CHARLES LEISERSON: No, OK.
Good.
Not good that
there's no questions.
It's good if there
are questions.
But good we'll move on.
So here's the idea.
Suppose Alice and Bob
dropped both tried
to enter the critical section.
And we have sequential
consistency.
So we can talk about who
did things in what order.
So whoever is the last one to
write to the variable turn,
that one's not going to enter.
And the other one will enter.
And then if Alice tries
to enter the section,
then she progresses
because at that point
she knows that B_wants is false.
And if only Bob
tries to enter it,
then he's going to
go because he's going
to see that A_wants is false.
Does that makes sense?
So only one of them is going
to be in there at a time.
It's also the case that you
want to verify that if you
want to enter, you can enter.
Because otherwise, a
very simple protocol
would be not to bother looking
at things but just take turns.
It's Alice's turn, it's Bob's
turn, it's Alice's turn,
it's Bob turn.
And we don't want a
solution like that
because if Bob doesn't want
a turn, Alice can't go.
She can go once, and
then she's stuck.
Whereas we want to be
able to have somebody,
if they're the
only one who wants
to go to execute the
critical section,
Alice can frob, frob,
frob, frob, frob.
Or Bob can borf, borf,
borf, borf, borf.
We don't want to force them to
go if they don't need to go.
So the intuition is
that only one of them
is going to get in
there because you
need the other one either
to say you want to go in,
or else their value for
wants is going to be 0.
And it's going to
be false and you're
going to go through anyway.
But this is not a good argument,
because this is handwaving.
We're at MIT, right,
so we can do proofs.
And this proof isn't so hard.
But I want to show
it to you because it
may be different from other
proofs that you've seen.
So here's the theorem.
Peterson's algorithm
achieves mutual exclusion
on the critical section.
The setup for the
proof is, assume
for the purposes
of contradiction
that both Alice and
Bob find themselves
in the critical
section together.
And now we're going to look
at the series of instructions
that got us there,
and then argue
there must be a contradiction.
That's the idea.
And so let's consider the most
recent time that each of them
executed the code before
entering the critical section.
So we're not interested
in what happened long ago.
What's the very,
very last pieces
of code as they entered
the critical section?
And we'll derive
a contradiction.
So here we go.
So without loss of generality,
let's assume that Bob--
we have some linear order.
And to execute, noticed a B
in the critical section, Alice
and Bob both had to
set the variable turn.
So one of them had
to do it first.
I'm going assume without
loss of generality
that it was Bob because I
can otherwise make exactly
the same argument for Alice.
So let's assume that Bob is
the last one to write to turn.
So therefore, if Bob
was the last one,
that means that Alice
writing to turn,
so she got in there
so she wrote to turn.
So her writing B to turn
preceded Bob writing A to turn.
So we have that happens
before relationship.
Everybody with me?
Do you understand the
notation I'm using
and the happens
before relationship?
Now Alice's program order
says that true to A_wants
comes before her
writing turn equals
B. That's just program order.
So we have that.
And similarly, we have
Bob's program order.
And Bob's program order says,
well, I wrote turn to A.
So Bob wrote, turn
equals A. And then Bob,
in this case I'm going
to do Bob read A_wants.
And then he reads turn.
So the second instruction
here, up here,
so this is a conditional and.
So we basically are doing this.
And then if that's
true, then we do this.
So this turn equals
equals A. That's
reading turn and checking if
it's A happens after A_wants.
So that's why I get these
three things in order.
Does that makes sense?
Any question about that?
Is that good?
So I've established
these two chains.
So I actually have
three chains here
that I'm now going to combine.
Let's see.
So what's happening
is let me look
to see what's the order of
everything that happens.
So the earliest
thing that happens
is that Alice wants
to be true because--
where's that?
So Alice wants is true
is, yes, is coming before.
That's the earliest thing
that's happening here.
So that instruction
is basically this--
Alice wants is true, it comes
before the A turn equals
B. That comes before
the A turn equals B.
So it comes before
the write turn equals
A, write B turn equals A.
And then B turn equals A.
So do you see the chain
we've established?
You see the chain?
Yeah, yeah.
OK, good.
|
So it says A_wants is first.
A_wants equals true is first.
Then we have the turn equals B.
That's all from the second line
here.
That's from this line here.
What's next?
Which instruction is next?
So turn equals A. That comes
from the top line there.
What's next?
STUDENT: B [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: So I
read B. Bob reads A_wants.
And then finally,
Bob reads turn at A.
So this is all based on just
the interleaving and the fact
that if you saw that we
have the program order
and that Bob was
the last to write.
That's all we're using.
And so why is that
a contradiction?
Well, we know what
the linear order is.
We know that when Bob
read, what did Bob read?
What did Bob read when he
read A_wants in step 4?
He read the last
value in that chain,
the most recent value In that
chain where it was stored to.
And what was stored there?
True.
Good.
And then Bob read turn.
And what was the
most recent value
stored to turn in that chain?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] A.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So then what?
STUDENT: Bob gets stuck.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Bob,
if that were in fact
what he read in the
while loop line, what
should be happening now?
He should be spinning there.
He shouldn't be in the loop.
Bob didn't obey.
His code did not obey
the logic of the code.
Bob should be spinning.
That's the contradiction.
Because we said Bob
was in the loop.
Does that makes sense?
Is that good?
So when you're confronted with
synchronizing through memory,
as this is called,
you really got
to write down the
happens before things
in order to be careful
about reviewing things.
I have seen in many,
many cases engineers
think they got it right
by an informal argument.
And in fact, for those
people who have studied
model checking-- anybody
have any interaction
with model checking?
What was the context?
STUDENT: 6.822.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Well, and were you
studying protocols and so forth?
STUDENT: Yeah.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So in
6.822, what class is that?
STUDENT: Formal programming.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Formal programing.
Good.
So for things like network
protocols and security
protocols and for cache
protocols in order
to implement things like MSI
and MESI protocols and so forth,
these days they can't
do it in their heads.
They have programs that look
at all the possible ways
of executing what's
called model checking.
And it's a great
technology because it
helps you figure out where the
bugs are and essentially reason
through this.
For simple things, you
can reason it through.
For larger things, you
use the same kind of
happens before analysis
in those contexts in order
to try to prove that
your program is correct,
that those protocols
are correct.
So for example, in
all the computers
you have in this room,
every one of them,
there was a model
checker checking
to make sure the cache
analysis was done.
And many of the
security protocols
that you're using as
you access the web
have all been through
model checking.
Good.
The other thing is it turns
out that Peterson's algorithm
guarantees starvation freedom.
So while Bob wants to
execute her critical session,
Bob cannot execute his critical
section twice in a row,
and vise versa.
So it's got the property that
one of the things that you
might worry about
is Alice wants to go
and then Bob goes
a gazillion times,
and Alice never gets to go.
Now that doesn't
happen, as you can see,
from the code because
every time you
go you set the turn
to the other person.
So if they do want to go,
they get to go through.
But proving that
is a nice exercise.
And it will warm you up
to this kind of analysis,
how you go about it.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Does it work
with another [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES LEISERSON:
This one does not.
And there has been
wonderful studies
of what does it take to get
n things to work together.
And this is one place where
the locks have a big advantage
because you can
use a single lock
to get the mutual
exclusion among n things,
so constant storage.
Whereas if you just use
atomic read and atomic write,
it turns out the storage grows.
And there's been
wonderful studies.
Also, wonderful studies
of these other operations,
like compare and
swap and so forth.
And we'll do a
little bit of that.
We'll do a little bit of that.
So often, in order
to get performance,
you want to synchronize
through memory.
Not often, but
occasionally you want
to synchronize through
memory to get performance.
But then you have to be
able to reason about it.
And so the happens before
sequential consistency,
great tools for doing it.
The only problem with
sequential consistency is what?
Who is listening?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's not real.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It's not real.
No, we have had
machines historically
that implemented
sequential consistency.
Today, no machines support
sequential consistency,
at least that I'm aware of.
Instead they report what's
called relaxed memory
consistency.
And let's take a look at
what the motivation is
for why you would want to make
it a nightmare for programmers
to synchronize through memory.
This has also led
software people
to say, never synchronize
through memory.
Why?
Because it is so hard
to get it correct.
Because you don't even
have sequential consistency
at your back.
So today, no modern
day processor
implements sequential
consistency.
They all implement some
form of relaxed consistency.
And in this context, hardware
actively reorders instructions,
and compilers may
reorder instructions too.
And that leads you not
to have the property
that the order of instructions
that you specify in a processor
is the same as the order
that they get executed in.
So you say do A and then B.
The computer does B and then A.
So let's see
instruction reordering.
So I have on the left the order
that the programmer specified,
and the order on the right
what the hardware did.
Or it may have been that
the compiler reordered them.
Now if you look, why might
the hardware or compiler
decide to reorder
these instructions?
What's going on in
You have to understand what
these instructions are doing.
So in the first case, I'm
doing a store and then a load.
And in the second case,
I have reversed the order
to do the load first.
Now if you think
about it, if you only
had one thing going
on, what's the impact
here of this reordering?
Is there any reason the
compiler or somebody
couldn't reorder these?
STUDENT: I think we reorder
them is the reason that it
affects the pipeline.
If you have to store first,
the write [INAUDIBLE]
you have to [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, in what way
does it affect the pipeline?
STUDENT: That basically the
load doesn't do anything
in the [INAUDIBLE],,
whereas the store does.
CHARLES LEISERSON: I think
you're on the right track.
There's a higher level
reason why you might want
to put loads before stores.
Why might you want to put loads?
These are two instructions
that normally if I only
had one thread, reordering
them would be perfectly fine.
Well, it's not necessarily
perfectly fine.
When might there be an issue?
It's almost perfectly fine.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
If A was equal to B.
But if A and B are
different, than reordering
them is just fine.
If A and B are the same, if
that's the same location,
uh-oh, I can't reorder them
because one is using the other.
So why might the hardware
prefer to put the load earlier?
Yeah?
STUDENT: There might be a later
instruction which depends on B.
CHARLES LEISERSON: There might
be a later instruction that
depends on B. And so why
would it put the load earlier?
STUDENT: So by doing
the load earlier,
the pipeline
[INAUDIBLE] happens.
Earlier on, [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, you're
basically covering over latency
in a load.
When I do a load, I have
to wait for the result
before I can use it.
When I do a store, I don't
have to wait for the result
because it's not being
used, I'm storing it.
And so therefore if
I do loads earlier,
If I have other work to do
such as doing the store,
then the instruction
that needs the value of B
doesn't have to
necessarily wait as long.
I've covered over
some of the latency.
And so the hardware
will execute faster.
So we've got higher performance
by covering load latency.
Does that makes sense?
It's helpful to know what's
going on in the hardware
here to reason
about the software.
This is a really great
example of that lesson
is what the compiler
is doing there
that it chooses to reorder.
And frankly, in
the era before 2004
when we were in the
era of what's called
Dennard scaling,
and we didn't worry.
All our computers just had one
processor, it didn't matter.
Didn't have to worry
about these issues.
These issues only come
up for when you have
more than one thing going on.
Because if you're sharing
these values, oops,
I changed the order.
So let's see, so when is
it safe in this context
for the hardware
compiler to perform
this particular reordering?
When can I do that?
So there's actually
two answers here.
Or there's a combined answer.
So we've already talked
about one of them.
Yeah?
STUDENT: When A is not B.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, when A
is not B. If A and B are equal,
it's not safe to do.
And what's the second
constraint where
it's safe to this reordering?
Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: If A
equals B, but if you
have already one [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Ooh,
that's a nasty one.
Yeah, I guess that's true.
I guess that's true.
But more generally
when is it safe?
That's a benign race
in some sense, right?
Yeah?
Good.
Good, that's a good one.
What's the other case
that this is safe to do?
Or what's the case
where it's not safe?
Same question.
I just told you.
When might this be safe?
When is it safe to
this reordering?
I can't do it if
A is equal to B.
And also shouldn't do it when?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] value of A.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, but.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
if you have like
when a processor is operating.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
if there's no concurrency.
If there's no
concurrency, it's fine.
The problem is when
there's concurrency.
So let's take a look at how
the hardware does reordering
so that we can understand
what's going on.
Because in a modern
processor, there's
concurrency all the time.
And yet the compiler
still wants to be
able to cover overload
latency, because usually it
doesn't matter.
So you can view
hardware as follows.
So you have a processor
on the left edge here,
and you have a network
that connects it
to the memory system, a
memory bus of some kind.
Now it turns out
that the processor
can issue stores faster than
the network can handle them.
So the processor can go store,
store, store, store, store.
But getting things
into the memory system,
that can take a while.
Memory system is
big and it's slow.
But the hardware is usually
not doing store on every cycle.
It's doing some other
things, so there are bubbles
in that instruction stream.
And so what it does
is it says, well, I'm
going to let you
issue it because I
don't want to hold you up.
So rather than
being held up, let's
just put them into a buffer.
And as long as there's
room in the buffer,
I can issue them as
fast as I need to.
And then the memory system can
suck them out of the buffer
as it's going along.
And so in critical places where
there's a bunch of stores,
it stores them in the buffer if
the memory system can't handle.
On average, of
course, it's going
to go at whatever the bottleneck
is on the left or the right.
You can't go faster
than whichever
is the bottleneck--
usually the memory system.
But we'd like to
achieve that, and we
don't want to have to stall
every time we try to do two
stores in a row, for example.
By putting a little
bit of a buffer,
we can make it go faster.
Now if I try to do a load,
that can stall the processor
until it's satisfied.
So whenever you do a load, if
there's no more instructions
to execute it, if the next
instruction to execute
requires the value
that's being loaded,
the processor has to stall
until it gets that value.
So they don't want the loads
to go through the store buffer.
I mean, one solution would
be just put everything
into the store buffer.
In some sense you'd
be OK, but now I
haven't covered over
my load latency.
So instead what they do is they
do what's called a load bypass.
They go directly to the
memory system for the load,
bypassing all the writes that
you've done up to that point
and fetch it so that you
get it to the memory system
and the load bypass takes
priority over the store buffer.
But there's one problem
with that hack, if you will.
What's the problem
with that hack?
If I bypass the load, where
could I run into trouble
in terms of correctness?
Yeah?
STUDENT: If one your
stores is the thing
you're trying to load.
CHARLES LEISERSON: If one
of your stores is the thing
you're trying to load.
Exactly.
And so what happens is, as
the load bypass is going by,
it does an associative
check in the hardware.
Is the value that I'm fetching
one of the values that
is in the store buffer?
And if so, it responds
out of the store buffer
directly rather than going
into the memory system.
Makes sense?
So that's how the reordering
happens within the machine.
But by this token, a
load can bypass a store
to a different address.
So this is how the hardware
ends up reordering it,
because the appearance
is that the load occurred
before the store occurred
if you are looking
at the memory from the
point of view of the memory,
and in particular
the point of view
of another processor that's
accessing that memory.
So over here I said, store load.
Over here it looks like
he did, load store.
And so that's why it doesn't
satisfy sequential consistency.
Yeah, question?
STUDENT: So that
store bumper would
be one for each processor?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
there's one for each processor.
It's the way it gets things
into the memory, right?
So I'll tell you,
computing would be so easy
if we didn't worry
about performance.
Because if those guys didn't
worry about performance,
they'd do the correct thing.
They'd just put them
in in the right order.
It's because we care about
performance that we make
our lives hard for ourselves.
And then we have these
kludges to fix them up.
So that's what's going on
in the hardware, that's
why things get reordered.
Makes sense?
But it's not as if
all bets are off.
And in fact, x86 has a
memory consistency model
they call total store order.
And here's the rules.
So it's a weaker model.
And some of it is kind of
sequentially consistent type
of thing.
You're talking about
what can be ordered.
So first of all, loads are
never reordered with loads.
Let me see here.
Yeah, so you never
reorder loads with loads.
That's not OK.
Always, you can
count on loads being
seen by any external
processor in the same order
that you issued the loads
within a given processor.
So there is some rationale here.
Likewise, stores are not
reordered with stores.
That never happens.
And then stores are not
reordered with prior loads.
So you never move a store
earlier past a load.
You wouldn't want to do
that because generally it's
the other direction you're
covering over latency.
But in fact, they guarantee
it doesn't happen.
So you never move a
store before a load.
It's always move a
load before a store.
And then in general, a load may
be reordered with a prior store
to a different location,
but not with a prior load
to the same location.
So this is what were
just talking about,
that A has to be not
equal to B in order
for it to be reordered.
And at the point that
you're executing this,
the hardware knows
what the addresses
are that are being loaded
and stored and can tell,
are they the same
location or not.
And so it knows whether or
not it's able to do that.
So the loads basically,
you can move loads upwards.
But you don't reorder them.
And you only move
it past a store
if it's a store to
a different address.
And so here we have
a bunch of things.
So this is basically weaker
than sequential consistency.
There are a bunch
of other things.
So for example, if I just
go back here for a second.
The lock instructions
respect a total order.
The stores respect
a total order.
The lock instructions
and memory ordering
preserves what they call
transitive visibility.
In other words, causality,
which is basically the happens--
says that the happens
before a relation,
you can treat as if
it's a linear order.
It's transitive as
a binary relation.
So the main important ones
are the ones at the beginning.
But it's helpful to
know that locks are not
going to get reordered.
If you have a lock
instruction, they're never
going to move it before things.
So here's the
impact of reordering
on Peterson's algorithm.
Sorry, no, this is not
Peterson's algorithm yet.
This impact of
reordering on this
is that I may have written
things in this order,
but in fact they execute in
something like this order.
And therefore, the
ordering, in this case,
2, 4, 1, 3 is going to
produce the value 0,
0, which was exactly
the value that you said
couldn't possibly appear.
Well, on these
machines it can appear.
And also let me say, so
instruction reordering violates
this sequential consistency.
And by the way, this can happen.
Not just in the hardware, this
can happen in the compiler
as well.
The compiler can decide
to reorder instructions.
It's like, oh my god,
how can we be writing
correct code at all right.
But you've written some
correct parallel code,
and you didn't have
to worry about this.
So we'll talk about
how we get there.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is the hardware geared
to even reorder [INAUDIBLE]??
Or [INAUDIBLE] it might happen?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It might happen.
No, there's no requirement
that it move things earlier.
STUDENT: Why is it not
always [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It may be that there
isn't enough register space.
Because as you move
things earlier,
you're going to have to
hold the values longer
before you're using them.
Yeah?
STUDENT: In the previous slide,
[INAUDIBLE] load 3 [INAUDIBLE]
also.
CHARLES LEISERSON: That
load 3 in the previous--
I'm sorry, I'm not following.
STUDENT: In the previous slide.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Oh, the
previous slide, not this slide.
This one?
STUDENT: Yeah.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
STUDENT: So [INAUDIBLE]
load 3 [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Well, I had said
there's some things that I
said we're no good, right?
So here it was, what did I do?
I moved the loads
earlier in that example.
But there were
some earlier ones.
Are you talking about
even earlier than that?
STUDENT: Yeah, this one.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Oh, this one, OK.
STUDENT: So, load 3 can come
before store [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: So let's see.
So this is the original thing.
Store 3 is before store
4, and load 3 and load 4
are afterwards, right?
So the stores have to
be in the same order
and the loads have to
be in the same order.
But the loads can
go before the stores
if they're to a
different address.
So in this case, we
moved load 3 up two,
and we moved load 4 up one.
We could have maybe move
load 4 up before store 3,
but maybe they were
to the same address.
STUDENT: OK, so load 3's store
doesn't mean that they're
from the same address?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No,
no, this is abstract.
You got it?
OK.
So this is why things
can get reordering.
And in that case, we can end up
with a reordering that gives us
something that we
don't expect when we're
synchronizing through memory.
Never write
non-deterministic code,
because you deal
with this stuff--
unless you have to.
Unfortunately, sometimes, it's
not fast enough otherwise.
Now let's go back and look
at Peterson's algorithm
and what can go wrong
with Peterson's algorithm.
So what reordering might happen
here that would completely
screw up Peterson's algorithm?
A hint, we're looking
for a load that
might happen before a store.
What load would be really
bad to happen before a store?
Yeah?
STUDENT: If you load turn to
[INAUDIBLE] before the store
turn [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
You load turn earlier.
Maybe.
Let me think, that's
not the one I chose,
but maybe that could be right.
Well, you can't move it
before the store to turn.
STUDENT: All right.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, yeah?
STUDENT: Maybe Alice
loads B_wants to early?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, if
Alice loads B_wants to early,
and if they both do, then
they could be reordered
before the store of
A_wants and B_wants,
because that's a load
and B_wants-- well,
Alice isn't touching
B_wants so why can't it just
move it earlier.
Those are not the
same locations.
So suppose it reorders
those, now what happens?
STUDENT: So [INAUDIBLE]
B_wants [INAUDIBLE] too early?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, it
would be false too early,
right?
STUDENT: And the
same with A_wants.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
And the same with A.
And now they discover they're in
this critical section together.
And if there's one thing,
we don't want Alice and Bob
in the same critical section.
Does that makes sense?
So you've got this problem.
There's reordering going on.
And, yikes, how
could you possibly
write any parallel code
and any concurrent code?
Well, they say, well,
we'll put in a kludge.
They introduce some
new instructions.
And this instruction is
called a memory fence.
So don't get me wrong.
They need to do stuff like this.
There is an argument to say
they should still build machines
with sequential
consistency because it's
been done in the past.
It is hard work for the
hardware designers to do that.
And so as long as
the software people
say, well, we can handle
weak consistency models,
[INAUDIBLE] says,
OK, your problem.
So Mark Hill, who's a professor
at University of Wisconsin,
has some wonderful
essays saying why
he thinks that parallel
machines should support
sequential consistency, and that
the complaints of people not
having it supported, that those
people they could support it
if they really wanted to.
And I tend to be
persuaded by him.
He's a very good
thinker, in my opinion.
But in any case, so what
we have-- yeah, question?
STUDENT: How much
of a difference
does it make to sacrifice?
CHARLES LEISERSON: So
he talks about this
and what he thinks
the differences is,
but it's apples and oranges.
Because sometimes
part of it is what's
the price of having
bugs in your code.
Because that's what
happens is programmers
can't deal with this.
And so we end up with
bugs in our code.
But they can reason about
sequential consistency.
It's hard, but they
can reason about it.
When you start having relaxed
memory consistency, very
tricky.
So let's talk about
what the solutions are.
And his argument is
that the performance
doesn't have to be that bad.
There was a series
of machines made
by a company called Silicon
Graphics, which were all
sequentially consistent.
Parallel machines, all
And they were fine.
But they got killed
in the market
because they couldn't implement
processors as well as Intel
does.
And so they ended up
getting killed in the market
and getting bought
out, and so forth.
And now their
people are all over,
and the people who were at
Silicon Graphics, many of them
really understand
parallel computing well,
the hardware aspects of it.
So a memory fence
is a hardware action
that forces an
ordering constraint
between the instructions
before and after the fence.
So the idea is, you can put a
memory fence in there and now
that memory fence
can't be reordered
with things around it.
It maintains its relative
ordering site to other things.
And that way you can prevent.
So one way you could make any
code be sequentially consistent
is to put a memory fence
between every instruction.
Not very practical, but
there's a subset of those
that actually would matter.
So the idea is to put
in just the run one.
You can issue them
explicitly as an instruction.
In the x86, it's called
the mfence instruction.
Or it can be
performed implicitly,
so there are other things like
locking, exchanging, and other
synchronizing instructions.
They implicitly
have a memory fence.
Now the compiler
that we're using
implements a memory
fence via the function
atomic_thread_fence, which is
defined in the C header file
stdatomic.h.
And you can take a look
at the reference material
on that to understand a
little bit more about that.
The typical cost
on most machines
is comparable to that
of an L2 cache access.
Now one of the things that
is nice to see is happening
is they are bringing that down.
They're making that cheaper.
But it's interesting that
Intel had one processor where
the memory fence
was actually slower
than the lock instruction.
And you say, wait a minute,
the lock instruction
has an implicit
memory fence in it.
I mean, you've got a memory
fence in the lock instruction.
How could the memory
fence be slower?
So I don't know exactly how this
happens, but here's my theory.
So you've got these
engineering teams
that are designing
the next processor.
And they of course
want it to go fast.
So how do they know whether
it's going to go fast?
They have a bunch
of benchmark codes
and that they discover,
well, now that we're
getting the age of parallelism,
all these parallel codes,
they're using locking.
So they look and
they say, OK, we're
going to put our best engineer
on making locks go fast.
And then they see
that, well, there's
some other codes that maybe
go slow because they've
got fences.
But there aren't too
many codes that just
need fences, explicit fences.
In fact, most of
them use [INAUDIBLE]..
So they put their junior
engineer on the fence code,
not recognizing that, hey, the
left hand and the right hand
should know what
each other is doing.
And so anyway,
you get an anomaly
like that where it turned out
that it was actually fastest--
we discovered as we're
implementing the silk runtime--
to do a fence by just
doing a lock on a location
that we didn't care
about the lock.
We just did a lock instruction.
And that actually went faster
than the fence instruction.
Weird.
But these systems are
all built by humans.
So if we have this code and we
want to restore consistency,
where might we put
a memory fence?
Yeah?
STUDENT: After setting the turn?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
After setting turn.
You mean like that?
STUDENT: Yeah.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
OK, so that you can't
end up loading it
before it's stored too.
And that kind of works, sort of.
You also have to make sure that
the compiler doesn't screw you
over.
And the reason
the compiler might
screw you over is that it
looks at B_wants and turn B,
it says, oh, I'm in a loop here.
So let me load the value and
keep using the value over.
And I don't see anybody
using this value.
Right, so it loads the value.
And now it just keeps
checking the value.
The value has changed
on the outside,
but it's stored
that in a register
so that that loop
will go really fast.
And so it goes really
fast, and you're spinning
and you're dead in the water.
So in addition to
the memory fence,
you must declare
variables as volatile
to prevent the compiler
from optimizing them away.
When you declare
something as volatile,
you say, even if you read
it, if the compiler reads it.
When it reads it a
second time, it's
still got to read it a
second time from memory.
It cannot assume that the
value is going to be stable.
You're saying it
may change outside.
And then you also, it turns
out, may need compiler fences
around frob and borf to
prevent them reordering
some of frob and borf because
that stuff can also sometimes
get moved outside the loop, the
actual code in frob and borf,
because it wants
to, it says, oh.
It doesn't realize always that
there's no what's going on.
So the C11 language standard
defines its own weak memory
model.
And you can declare
things as atomic,
and there are a bunch
of things there.
And here's a reference
where you can
take a look at the
atomic stuff that's
available if you want to do
this dangerous programming.
In general for implementing
general mutexes,
if you're going to use
only load and store,
there's a very nice theorem
by Burns and Lynch--
this is Nancy Lynch who's
on the faculty here--
that says any n-thread
deadlock-free mutual exclusion
algorithm using only load and
store requires order n space--
the space is linear.
So this answers the question
that I had answered orally
before.
And then it turns
out that if you
want an n-thread deadlock-free
mutual exclusion algorithm,
you actually have to use some
kind of expensive operation,
such as a memory fence or
an atomic compare-and-swap.
So in some sense,
hardware designers
are justified when they
implement special operations
to support animosity,
as opposed to just doing
using these clever algorithms.
Those algorithms are
really at some level
of theoretical interest.
So let's take a look at one
of these special instructions.
And the one I picked
is compare-and-swap
because it's the one that's
probably most available.
There are others like
test-and-set, and so forth.
And so when you do
lock-free algorithms,
when you want to build
algorithms that are lock free,
and we'll talk
about why you might
want to do lock-free algorithms,
there's loads and store,
and then there's this CAS
instruction, Compare-and-Swap.
In stdatomic.h, it is called
atomic_compare_exchange_strong.
And it can operate on
various integer types.
It cannot compare and swap
floating point numbers.
It can only compare
and swap integers,
and sometimes that's a pain.
And so here's the definition
of the CAS instruction.
Basically, what it does
is it has an address.
And then it has two values, the
old value and the new value.
And what it does is
it checks to see,
is the value that is
in that memory location
the same as the old value.
And if it is, it sets it
to the new value and says,
I succeeded.
And otherwise, it says I failed.
So it swaps it if the value
that I'm holding, the old value,
is the same as what's in there.
So I can read the
value, if I want,
then do whatever I want to do.
And then before I
update it, I can say,
update it only if the
value hasn't changed.
And that's what the
compare and swap does.
Does that makes sense?
And it does that
all atomically,.
And there's an
implicit fence in there
so things don't get
reordered around it.
It's all done as one.
The hardware ensures that
nothing can interfere
in the middle of this.
It's actually comparing the
old value to what's in there,
and swapping in the new,
all as one operation.
Or it says, nope, the
value changed, therefore
it just returned false, and
the value didn't get updated.
So it turns out that you can
do an n-thread deadlock-free
mutual exclusion algorithm
with compare-and-swap
using only constant space.
And here's the way you do it.
And this is basically just the
space for the new text itself.
So you take a look at the
lock instruction, and what
you do is you spin, which is
to say you block, until you
finally get the value true.
So you're trying
to swap in true.
So true says that
somebody holds the lock.
I say the old value was false.
If it's true, then the
swap doesn't succeed
and you just keep spinning.
And then otherwise,
you swap in the value
and now you're ready to go.
And to unlock it, you just
have to set it to false.
Question?
STUDENT: Why does
it de-reference
the pointer in the lock?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Why does
it de-reference the pointer?
Because you're saying,
what memory location
are you pointing to.
You're interested in
comparing with the value
in that location.
So it is a memory operation.
So I'm naming the
memory location.
I'm saying, if the value
is false, swap in the value
true and return true.
And if it's true, then don't
do anything and tell me
that you didn't succeed,
in which case in this loop
it'll just keep trying
again and again and again.
It's a spinning lock.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
when you saying
that you're [INAUDIBLE]
the value at that address
before passing it into CAS.
Yeah, there shouldn't be a
pointer de-reference after
[INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Oh, you're right.
A bug.
Gotcha, yep,
gotcha, I'll fix it.
So let's take a look at a way
that you might want to use CAS.
So here's a summing problem.
So suppose I want to compute
on some variable of type x.
And I've got an array that's--
what is that-- that's a
million elements long.
And what I'm going
to do is basically
run through my array in
parallel and accumulate things
into the result.
And so this is actually
incorrect code.
Why is this incorrect code?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Extra like a floating
point taken [INAUDIBLE]
and so forth?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Maybe,
let's assume we have fast math.
Yeah?
STUDENT: You have multiple
transfer and updated results
at the same time?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Which means what?
STUDENT: Which means
you have a race.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
You have a race.
Everybody is trying
to update result.
You've got a gazillion
strands in parallel all trying
to pound on updating result.
So one way you could solve
this is with mutual exclusion.
So I introduce a mutex L.
And I lock before I update
the result, and then I unlock.
Why did I put the
computation on my array of i?
Why did I put that
outside the lock?
STUDENT: It's [INAUDIBLE]
function is very expensive.
That way, you're
only locking the--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, whenever you lock,
you want to lock for the
minimum time possible.
Because otherwise you're
locking everybody else
out from doing anything.
So that was a smart thing
in that particular code.
So that's the typical
locking solution.
But look at what might happen.
What if the operating
system decides
to swap out a loop iteration
just after it acquires mutext?
As you go down, it says lock.
You get the lock, and now
the operating says, oops,
your time quantum is up.
Somebody else comes in
and starts to compute.
What's going to happen now?
What's the problem
that you might observe?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] if
they're [INAUDIBLE] computation
[INAUDIBLE] have to [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, everybody's
going to basically
just sit there waiting
to acquire the lock because
the strand that has the lock
is not making progress, because
it's sitting on the side.
It's been these scheduled.
That's bad, generally.
You'd like to think that
everybody who's running
could continue to run.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Well, I guess
under what circumstances
might be useful for
a processor to have
this running on multi-threads
instead of multiple processors
simultaneously?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No, so
this the multiple threads
are running on multiple
processors, right?
STUDENT: What do you
mean by the time quantum?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
So one of these guys
says, so I'm running a thread,
and that thread's time quantum
expires.
STUDENT: Oh, that
processor's multiple threads.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Right.
STUDENT: OK.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So I've got
a whole bunch of processors
with a thread on
each, let's say.
And I've got a bunch of threads.
The operating system
has several threads
that are standing by
waiting for their turn.
And one of them grabs the
lock and then the scheduler
comes in and says, oops,
I'm going to take you off,
put somebody else in.
But meanwhile, everybody else is
there trying to make progress.
And this guy is holding
the key to going forward.
You thought you were
only grabbing the lock
for a short period of time.
But instead, the
operating system
came in and made you
take a long time.
So this is the kind
of system issue
that you get into when you
start using things like locks.
So all the other loop
iterations have to wait.
So it doesn't matter if--
yeah, question?
STUDENT: How does the
[INAUDIBLE] reducer
have [INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: So that's
one solution to this, yep.
STUDENT: How does it do it?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
How does it do it?
We have the paper online.
I had the things for
explaining how reducers work.
And there's too much stuff.
I always have way more stuff
to talk about than I ever
get a chance to talk about.
So that was one where
I said, OK, yeah.
STUDENT: OK.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
So all we want to
do is atomically
execute a load of x
followed by a store of x.
So instead of doing
it with locks,
I can use CAS to
do the same thing,
and I'll get much
better properties.
So here's the CAS solution.
So what I do is I
also compute a temp,
and then I have these
variables old and new.
I store the old result. And
then I add the temporary result
that I've computed to the
old to get the new value.
And if it turns out that the old
value is exactly the same as it
used to be, then I can
swap in the new value,
which includes that increment.
And if not, then I go
back and I do it again.
I once again load, add,
and try to swap in again.
And so now what happens if
the operating system swaps out
a loop iteration?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's OK because
whenever this is put back on,
then you know
it'll be different.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It'll be
new values, it'll ignore it,
and all the other guys
can just keep going.
So that's one of
the great advantages
of lock-free algorithms.
And I have in here several
other lock-free algorithms.
The thing you should
pay attention in here
is to what's called
the ABA problem, which
is an anomaly with
compare-and-swap
that you can get into.
This is a situation
where you think
you're using compare-and-swap,
you say is it the old value.
It turns out that the
value is the same,
but other people have come in
and done stuff but happened
to restore the same value.
But you assume it's
the same situation,
even though the
situation has changed
but the value is the same.
That's called the ABA problem.
So you can take a
look at it in here.
So the main thing
for all this stuff
is, this is really
interesting stuff.
Professor Nir Shavit
teaches a class where
this is the content of
the class for the semester
is all these really
dangerous algorithms.
And so I encourage you, if
you're interested in that.
The world needs more
people who understand
these kinds of algorithms.
And it needs to find ways
to help people program fast
where people don't have
to know this stuff,
because this is
really tricky stuff.
So we need both--
both to make it so
that we have people
who are talented in
this way, and also
that we don't need
their talents.
OK, thanks, everybody.